Tony Dungy has been on fire with Twitter
who knew that Tony even knew how to use
Twitter but here's Tony who said please
NFL do us a favor and don't let coaches
challenge anymore past interference
calls you're causing teams to lose
timeouts making your officiating
Department looking amped making us fans
look feel stupid like we don't know the
meaning of clear obvious and significant
Tony Dungy joins us on the program
Tony did you hear from anybody with the
NFL after that tweet we got 30,000 likes
Dan we went in you know we always go in
and we get our briefing from the league
and they talked about how they were
going to implement this review system
and I had some concerns then but it
really has been bad because it puts the
coaches in a bad situation because
basically they don't want to overturn
anything and to me they should have just
been out front and said you know what
we're gonna have this mechanism coach
you can't do anything if we get to the
playoffs and we see others just
horrendous and we'll change it but until
then don't worry about things but they
had to coach this feeling like okay if
there's a an egregious past interference
that was wrong or one that was move will
change it but started in Week three they
have not changed anything and it's put
the coaches in a really bad situation
but Tony can you resend this rule now
can you can you say we're going to get
rid of it I think they should that would
be the best thing I don't think they
will kind of ride it out to the end of
the year but now with all these calls
that they have let girl and they haven't
changed there were Susan's like in
Monday night denying Salas game you know
and I can sympathize with pad summer
he's sitting there so there's there's a
clear pass and if it isn't called he's
gonna have first and rule about the six
yard line and a crucial point in the
game he knows they don't want to review
it and reverse it but he's got 50,000
fans saying the Jumbotron and they were
screaming and so what he could either
say well yeah I'm not gonna say he
challenges loses his timeout and it's
just terrible
but if he doesn't challenge it then the
fans are gonna be all over him yeah they
just they put the coaches that are
no-win situation I think they put our
wives in a no-win situation because I
don't believe him I mean he knows what
passes apheresis
he knows these obvious cold I think
someone has said we don't want anything
changed until it gets to the clay oh
yeah but I don't understand that Tony it
just makes the NFL look bad it makes
these official look bad I would rather
get rid of replay entirely because it I
just I feel I don't know what who's up
to something here or why they don't want
the officials to be embarrassed or
whatever it is but when we see it and
then they don't change it then they look
bad it makes the product look bad so
what is the agenda here yeah absolutely
worse than even we make bad calls as
coaches and we wish we could take back
players drop passes players jump
offsides mistake Hoffman are going to
miss call it's part of the game but now
when you have a system in place and say
okay yeah they missed it but you know
what we're going to act like it didn't
happen that nobly words I mean that
makes everybody look bad and that right
now he's Tony Dungy the Hall of Famer
former NFL head coach and of course
member of NBC football night in America
joining his Continental Tire Coach's
Corner
I we were talking to Peter King in the
first hour about a couple things with
Cam Newton at age 30 not able to be the
Super Man Cam Newton more of a pocket
passer maybe but if you're Carolina have
you seen enough with Kyle Allen have you
seen enough with Cam Newton that you
move on from this situation I think a
lot of this is gonna come down to money
to me Cam Newton healthy and vigorous
until next year but can news and healthy
still gives you a way better chance to
win and with Allen's okay what if you're
talking about Cam Newton that thirty
million dollars and
a Lynette at 1 million you know that
that's a different thing and now you've
got to decide how you put this thing
together I think you kind of get going
on on guys and this guy's going to be
tremendous and he's great and you know
the plateless defense is the best we've
ever seen and you can comment just let
things play out and and and we'll see
we'll see but you know the Pampas can
make a run now and it's unfortunate that
cams not going to be there but they're
gonna have to be evaluated at the end of
the year do you think in our lifetime we
see a football team that is primarily
based in London probably not in my
lifetime some things that have to get
situated it would be tough we had a
competitive disadvantage I know it's
going to bring some more money into the
details and maybe expanding the brand
but you know even gone East Coast the
west coast it's tough and now you put
your home base another four time zones
away and you have to solve all that I
think there's some problems that we
don't anticipate well if let's say the
Chargers did go there if you can put
them in the AFC East right you could you
could take one of those teams out of the
East and then that way at least you're
playing games that are going to be a
little easier for at least a good
portion of your schedule we'll be in a
leader time zone you could but then you
know how are they playing are they are
they coming to the state every other
week are they coming on board and then
we're games at home what comes up when
they do play the AFC West for instance
and they've got to work those person and
they've not the NFC you know they go to
Denver those are you know really really
long intro are they going to play on
Monday night or they fund a lot of
things the black cat running on the
football field on Monday night what's
the most bizarre thing that you ever
witnessed on
football field and you know the kissing
bandit lady that was all Morgana you
know in the 70s and 80s and when a
couple times trying to think what else
we had not not too much it seems like
the advent of TV and the nationally
televised game brings out things like
this did did one of your teammates on
the steelers tackle the streaker yeah
someone was running on the field and
that was kind of that that set the tone
everybody said I wish we didn't we want
a couple of it just kind of sit there
and chuckle and say you know we'd be
making bets on the side how long is it
going to take to get an uncertain 35
seconds but nothing people's our Tony
good to talk to you tell the boys I said
hello and thank you hopefully we can get
this Tony Dungy football night in
America for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]